to mark the 18th anniversary of
September 11th we are hearing from
former high school students who sat in
classrooms just three blocks away from
the twin towers attack a new HBO
documentary that premieres tonight
shares the story of eight alumni from a
prestigious high school right here in
New York City the documentary is called
in the shadow of the star in the shadow
rather of the towers Stuyvesant High on
9/11 revisits the events of 9/11 through
the perspective of teenagers who were
nearby that day are Adriana Diaz was one
of those students Adriana good morning I
heard that you were there yesterday I I
can't imagine what that was like for you
it's been a long time since I've been
back at this school I mean we all
remember where we were on 9/11 right I
was walking to school senior year and as
I was walking down the street I saw an
American Airlines plane across the sky
and the balls of fire coming out of the
first tower I didn't know what to do so
I went to school I told my calculus
teacher what happened and she said we
know but we have a quiz to take I think
she just wanted to maintain normalcy
right and the blinds were down so we
couldn't really see from the classroom
but my story's just one of millions from
that day and the images of that day or
how hard to watch
can you guys believe it's been 18 years
I'm blue you come across another person
who was there that's when everything
source sort of floods back in we were
all there three blocks away from the
Twin Towers on September 11th 2001
gieux que su was student body president
Lila Nordstrom became a health advocate
for 9/11 survivors and lives O'Callahan
and mohammed hawk my dad over the phone
said to me please please just survive or
in a new HBO documentary about the teens
who saw the towers and all normalcy
collapse in front of them I was staring
out at the window and I literally saw
flash and the first explosion so you
guys remember the building shaking oh
the lights flickered yeah that's when we
saw the dust cloud coming
that was scary that was scary
we're just kind of calming and
enveloping it felt like a scary movie
almost at the time it felt like the
buildings were crashing on to us right
because we didn't know what was in that
dust cloud I thought it was debris I
think I came out of these doors yeah I
think so as well so yeah and this is
where there was all the confusion
because the debris was kind of flowing
around the building up there and people
were pushing back pushing back because
the students were exiting the second
building was falling we just started
running up town up the highway there
were people from further downtown
covered head to foot in this off-white
powder they looked like ghosts I think
so many of us didn't share our full
stories with each other because everyone
else had their own story
I was not covered in dust I was not
joking I was not dead I didn't lose
anyone that day there's always somebody
else with a more harrowing story
I lost my uncle on September 11th I
can't even talk he was uh he lived with
my family for a little while I remember
he was the only person I was thinking
about on that day really I was here in
this library and seeing people falling
from from the towers and I remember just
feeling like he was there like he was
one of the people jumping out of the
towers less than a month after the
attack we returned to our school which
had been used as a command center and
morgue I think there was a point of
pride of not letting ourselves would be
too affected or letting ourselves show
that we were too affected I feel like
it's a pretty safe place to be and I
know that it'll bring back emotions for
me to be back in the building
but
think that it's things that I can cope
with there were a bunch of false
assurances made to the Parents
Association at the time about the
condition the school would be in when we
got back a lot of these conditions
hadn't actually been met so we were here
for about four months of consistent
fires burning a few blocks away the
smell of smoke was suffocating everyday
and despite assurances from officials
very little got done to clean the school
for students Nordstrom now fights for
services for 9/11 survivors I wanted to
tell Congress that there was this
population that was showing the same
results of the exposure that responders
are seeing I was 15 at the time Kathy
Choi who was in the documentary passed
away from gastric cancer after filming
that's a cancer that's linked by the
federal government to 911 Kathy's the
reason I'm here today I know it's not
something I typically talk about but
it's it's so important you know I'm so
grateful for advocacy the five of us
were largely not that close in high
school but we all knew each other and
like we all hugged each other when we
came in like there is an affection there
affection I captured in this camcorder
video I took of the last day of school
just shared experience
which could be very traumatic and tragic
has brought us all together there really
is a bond there it resented where we
live totally right we're all different
in the cities we all live in different
parts of the country but you know we
have that common core that we all share
there are health services and screenings
for people who are in downtown Manhattan
at the time we have information about
those resources at CBS this morning calm
now Lila the health care advocate she
says she knows 20 people who were in our
school who now have 911 related cancers
Cathy Choi who was in the documentary
who died of cancer was just 32 years old
the thing that always struck me was what
was the psychological impact gonna be
particularly on kids who were so close
to that my daughter asked me for six
months she was five every night she went
to bed for six months she said daddy if
they caught Osama bin Laden yet I'm like
what's the long-term effect of this and
and that's what I wonder about the kids
in your class it's something we don't
think about a lot but you kind of worry
about how it's affected you long-term
the significance of the attacks I think
you appreciate each year that goes by I
was 20 in Washington DC we were huddled
in a gym in the College of Georgia
Washington University and at the time I
don't think any of us appreciated just
what had happened but every year that
goes by it sinks in more no and I think
about you Adriana that the plane was so
close you could tell it was American
Airlines that you could I know I didn't
know that about you so to know that you
were right there and could actually see
the plane coming in is so frightening to
me it was the scary day no I will never
forget we'll be right back